Kia ora kotou
Warm greetings to everyone in our community.
Firstly, I want to acknowledge that for many
of you it’s been a difficult week.
I know there’s a high level of uncertainty
and things are changing almost on a daily basis.
I need to reassure you that the Council is
working extremely hard to support our community
and ensure all our essential services - water, roading, recycling and rubbish
will continue to operate smoothly through this difficult time.
We have followed Ministry of Health guidelines
and shut all Council building and facilities
in order protect our residents.
We are closely following the situation, and
as soon as it’s possible to reopen facilities,
we will do so.
In the meantime we’re adapting and finding ways for people
to access council services remotely.
Staff from departments such as the aquatic
facilities, are being redeployed to assist
our community in other areas when it’s safe
to do so.
Our libraries already offer a great range
of digital services you can access from home.
You can contact our Customer Services by email,
phone, Facebook or Snap, Send Solve.
As much as possible, we will still be carrying
out our normal activities, such as dog registrations,
LIMS and animal management.
We have streamlined our decision-making and
have formed a Covid 19 Response Committee
made up of Councillors, so our Council can
adapt quickly to any challenges that may arise.
Our Councillors are at this moment taking
another look through our budgets and at the
projects we had planned for the coming year.
It’s important that our infrastructure is
maintained, that we support our local contractors
and we keep planning for our future growth.
However there may be spending that can be
deferred until this situation is behind us.
I encourage you to listen and follow the advice
from the Government.
Remain calm, look after one another
and when the restrictions ease, support our local businesses as much as you can.
Our community is strong and resilient.
Our pandemic plans are up to date and Civil
Defence are ready to activate if needed.
We have been through hard times before, and
together, united, we will beat this virus.